la pregunta acá es la gran pregunta los
pensando en el referéndum es
cuánto
cuanto futuro los isleños quiero seguir
siendo parte de gran bretaña oa futuro
plantearán un gobierno autónomo también
son discusiones que en su momento se
dieron
y se dieron incluso nazis
al inicio de estas conmemoraciones que
ahora tienen lugar en buenos aires a
viatri nado el presidente de argentino
alberto fernández o 40 años después el
reconocimiento a nuestros héroes
veteranos y caídos y el reclamo legítimo
de soberanía sobre las islas malvinas
las malvinas fueron son y serán
argentinas esta es la posición oficial
del gobierno usted cree que haya lugar
para negociaciones en algún momento de
la historia porque hasta este momento
estaba completamente cerrada esa idea
y yo lo veo muy difícil comparto
plenamente las palabras de julio
en la recién nuestro de una posición tan
salvada
ha hecho durante que el conflicto esté
congelado o sea desde 1982 técnicamente
no han habido avances en las
negociaciones días hay reuniones con
algunos gobiernos que se tienen mejor
relación o por lo menos pero la verdad
es que concretamente en cuestiones de
soberanía no han habido más
entonces acá yo no sé si no tendríamos
el contacto previamente en que decía
julio si no tenemos que intentar empezar
este reclamo desde otros lados pensando
otras dimensiones escuchando otras voces
como las voces de los isleños no
significa acceder al reclamo de
soberanía
significa de capas que podemos proponer
una solución más creativa
que incluya que los incluyan
y que capaz incluya a las tres partes no
sé a mí me parece que en este momento si
no vamos a estar siempre en un punto
muerto
y ya en el plano geopolítico andrea
porque reinó unido- defiende con tanto
ahínco estas islas las islas malvinas
que albergan la base militar más grande
del hemisferio azul que además son un
foco de tráfico entre los océanos
atlántico y pacífico y que además son el
único paso en esa zona del mundo por el
que podrían atravesar los submarinos
nucleares en manos de la otan hablemos
un poco de la estrategia alrededor de
las islas malvinas
bueno lo que digamos un poco lo que
acaba de decir
es un lugar me enclave
justamente no a nivel legión político y
esto no fue tanto desde el siglo 19
cuando en otra época no
cuando se dio la toma la comunidad de
las filas de mil 833 como marco de una
estrategia imperialista británica como
lo sigue haciendo hoy hoy claramente
bueno se lo
ha calificado como un común
en clave economía no efectivamente ahí
hay es un lugar clave por todos los
recursos económicos pesqueros se piensa
que es capaz de petróleo pero hasta el
momento las excavaciones no han tenido
los resultados que esperaban
y aparte es clave por cómo está situado
luego por él en cuanto a podemos pensar
también en la antártida ay ay ay hay
mucho para pensar digamos espacialmente
de cómo se puede jugar a futuro
los recursos que hay en las islas y en
las cercanías